però larga è larga scusate ragazzi io lo
so che sono antica ma che significa
larga pro larga da tulug in inglese va
scatti a io la chiamavo latenza c'è
sempre qualcosa da imparare
25 febbraio 2020 la nostra vita stava
per cambiare e la didattica a distanza
ci avrebbe travolti come un treno
didattica a distanza strano termine vero
ma tutti voi l'avete sentito dire perché
quasi tutti sarete genitori
molti sono studenti e alcuni docenti e
didattica e di stanza nella stessa frase
sembrano quasi un ossimoro
e in effetti lo sono perché l'abbiamo
sentito dire mille volte la didattica è
una questione di sguardi di relazione di
presenza ed è proprio così perché se non
guardi i tuoi studenti perdi quasi tutto
ma lasciate che vi presenti gli studenti
gli studenti sono queste curiose
creature che passano gran parte della
mattinata nascoste dietro a un banco che
riadattano come se fosse una sorta di
trincea e dietro il quale si sentono al
sicuro e dietro al quale sono tutti
uguali
ora se potessi raccontarvi una giornata
con loro la riassume rai come un mix tra
una discesa dalle montagne russe il
video della canzone rock and roll high
school teramo nas non so se sapete la
parte in cui dicono non mi interessa la
storia perché
ad essere qui ecco questo rende
abbastanza l'idea ma se togliessimo loro
il banco è quello che ha fatto la
didattica a distanza ha tolto loro il
banco sottolineando i divari sociali che
ci sono non tutti hanno le stesse
opportunità
non tutti hanno gli stessi mezzi e lo
sguardo di cui parlavamo prima diventa
più profondo perché coglie aspetti che
in classe sono solo appena accennati e
allora proprio per queste nette
differenze che ci sono
noi dobbiamo mettere in moto e
accelerare su questo cambio di mentalità
perché sono gli studenti che sono loro
il vero motore del cambiamento sono loro
che ci spingono a rinnovare e come
vedete da questa foto noi abbiamo avuto
una grande opportunità cioè quella di
piantare il seme della curiosità che
germoglierà e crescerà se sapremo come
fare però non sempre le cose sono
semplici e noi non abbiamo un libretto
delle istruzioni o un procedimento
scritto per far germogliare questo seme
soprattutto la pianta non crescerà dove
e come vogliamo noi e allora noi docenti
che cosa possiamo fare per creare un eco
ambiente equilibrato
quando parlo di eco ambiente mi
riferisco allo spazio nel quale vivono
gli studenti lo spazio nel quale si
relazionano nel quale creano legami e
comunità e non importa che sia uno
spazio reale o uno spazio virtuale
perché i ragazzi rispondono velocemente
e meglio ai cambiamenti si adattano e si
reinventano però sta a noi creare le
condizioni favorevoli affinché anche chi
vive in un terreno più arido non sia
svantaggiato quindi restando sempre
nell'ambito vegetale possiamo dire che
la didattica in presenza è la luce del
sole
l'atmosfera è l'aria aperta che
circondano il tronco e le piante cioè
tronco germogli visto che li stiamo
coltivando è invece la didattica a
distanza è il sottosuolo nel quale
vivono le radici cioè questa parte
oscura e misteriosa dove però si formano
fitte reti di relazioni e che non si
avvale di uno sguardo in pieno giorno
però fa perno su un punto di vista molto
più profondo cioè sullo studente e sulle
sue situazioni circostanti quindi è per
questo che noi dobbiamo creare questo
eco ambiente e posso aiutarvi in questo
senso citando il professore stefano
mancuso quando in un suo bellissimo ted
si invita a ispirarsi alle piante
cioè noi nella scuola nel nostro piccolo
abbiamo fatto un cambiamento evolutivo e
il professor stefano mancuso ci dice
questo ci dice che le piante hanno
scelto di restare immobili e detto così
può sembrare la scelta sbagliata ma non
lo è è la scelta giusta perché come ci
ha dimostrato il lock down
stando fermi abbiamo potuto esplorare
l'ambiente didattico che non è
necessariamente il luogo fisico e
abbiamo potuto osservarlo nei minimi
dettagli per capire che cosa era
sbagliato e che cosa invece andava bene
e per poterlo perfezionare siamo stati
per lunghi lunghissimi mesi di fronte ad
uno schermo ed è questo schermo che ci
ha imposto la scelta evolutiva perché
noi potevamo scegliere continuare con
una didattica frontale e fingere di s
ascoltati perché in fondo parlavamo ad
uno schermo oppure potevamo lavorare
davvero per competenze potevamo davvero
assegnare compiti di realtà e potevamo
davvero valorizzare le attitudini di
ogni singolo studente
la didattica a distanza ci ha insegnato
molte cose prima di tutto abbiamo capito
che dobbiamo valorizzarli che dobbiamo
farli crescere e che dobbiamo crescere
con loro e abbiamo capito che non è
importante il luogo in cui noi li
valorizziamo è stato a noi portare
avanti questo cambiamento è stato a noi
portare avanti questo cambio di ambiente
e vi faccio un esempio se io ora vi
dicessi prendete il libro e studiate i
problemi sulla sicurezza da pagina 138 a
pagina al 151 poi rispondete a tutte le
domande
ecco adesso potrei anche un po mettermi
a ridere
nel senso che vi immagino cercare tutti
quanti con molta solerzia il libro per
rispondere alle domande felici di farlo
no immagino di no ed è così anche per
gli studenti
e se io invece ora vi dicessi bene ora
che abbiamo approfondito l'argomento
ciascuno di voi scelga un tema un tema
da esporre ai vostri compagni cioè voi
dovrete parlare ai vostri coetanei e
dovrete esporre questo tema in maniera
creativa
cioè non dovrete usare un power point e
chi vi sorprenderà avrà a disposizione
10 punti wow per migliorare il proprio
voto
ora questo esperimento che io ho fatto
nella mia classe mi ha dato dei
risultati straordinari perché non c'è
stato un ragazzo che non abbia
consegnato nei tempi stabiliti e non ce
n'è stato uno che non ha
abbia lavorato per accaparrarsi 10 punti
wow un ragazzo ha fatto recitare i suoi
genitori in un video
ora vi faccio una domanda secondo voi
quanto erano felici quei genitori che io
fossi l'insegnante del figlio
ecco forse non tanto ma scherzavo perché
la vera domanda che voglio farvi a
questa secondo voi quanto era importante
l'ambiente in cui ho chiesto di
realizzare questo esercizio chiederlo in
un ambiente fisico o in un ambiente
virtuale ha fatto la differenza
no quello che conta l eco ambiente in
cui l'ho chiesto e la rete di relazioni
che ho sfruttato per raggiungere i miei
obiettivi
quindi la didattica a distanza è stata
ed è un'opportunità per scardinare la
scuola dall'interno e per ribaltare i
ruoli imposti essere insegnanti è la
messa a disposizione el accoglienza
verso l'altro ed è accompagnare i
ragazzi al raggiungimento del loro
obiettivo è il mio consiglio è che
proprio come in un ted noi docenti non
dobbiamo trasmettere conoscenza ma
dobbiamo dare agli studenti gli
strumenti per costruirsela idea dopo
idea
camminando al loro fianco e ricordandoci
che ciascuno di loro è diverso dagli
altri
a prescindere dall'ambiente in cui si
trova dall'ambiente in cui è cresciuto
tanti tanti anni fa un uomo prima di noi
un uomo molto più saggio di noi mi avete
sentito parlare a un certo plutarco
disse gli studenti non sono quasi da
riempire ma fiaccole da accendere
ed è proprio così sono gli studenti che
ci chiedono di accendere la fiaccola
della loro curiosità e noi dovremmo
imparare
ad ascoltarli ea dare loro fiducia
siamo stati distanti ma mai così
profondamente vicini come nel periodo
del lab dow e questa esperienza deve
servirci per riflettere per
riconsiderare le nostre posizioni e per
generare i cambiamenti
apprendiamo dalle piante come vivere e
osservare non siamo al centro del mondo
e non siamo sul palcoscenico ma se nel
breve tempo che ci ha dato
vogliamo essere incisivi dobbiamo prima
di tutto diventare spettatori attenti
perché solo così potremo costruire un
eco ambiente adatto alla coscienza di
chi apprende cioè ai nostri ragazzi che
spesso pos troviamo con parole ingiuste
ma che se ci pensiamo bene sono la
nostra unica speranza vorrei concludere
ricordando un uomo che ha speso la sua
vita per un'idea di scuola creativa ed
inclusiva e che ci ha lasciati poco
tempo fa prematuramente serkan robinson
vi chiedo per lui un applauso grazie
[Applauso]